you guys were so nice I took I went with
with just a small skeleton crew I went
to Armenia and the idea was to take my
assistant Sona moves Sen back to her
native country and had this amazing
experience and you guys reached out and
said look we have a television show you
can come on and be a guest they had me
on their show and it was a really nice
gesture so thank you thank you well it
is a political satire show and I believe
we try to get some political forecasts
from you yes this was when the election
our presidential election I don't
remember exactly when this one do you
remember when as well as 2015 October
and you made some predictions yeah I
made some predictions
yes I know what you're gonna talk about
okay video of this great let's show this
this is obviously early in the u.s.
presidential election October people
celebrate and they were asking me some
questions about what was gonna happen
let's take a look we're kind of
following the campaign the primaries in
us yes we caught this guy Donald Trump
yes and from here from thousands of
miles away he looks kind of crazy
gasps yeah yeah we're just wondering
from up close Americans do for Americans
does he seem more reasonable no no no no
no more crazy crazy we are as afraid as
you are we're all equally afraid so will
not be will not be he will not be
President
now
so explain yourself Conan listen I'm
right half the time I think I was
reflecting what a lot of people thought
in October of 2015
well you apologize I know that I yeah
you blame me now because I declared he
would not become president
so Politico is not asking you to write
any articles anytime soon yeah I know I
know I've lost all my credibility along
with the New York Times
you